foreign
Chuck I want to fill you in on a couple
of things okay okay I'm always available
to hear Americans are famously
non-metric you know
because it you know we like attention do
I need to remind you
that U.S currency
is metric
hold on how is dollar how does dollar
mean metric because it's a hundred
pennies in the dollar oh okay okay
you're right that's that's it's base 10
yeah you're right yes it is okay okay
our currency and it was metric even at a
time where British currency wasn't
that's right the pound the pound
Shillings Pence all that crap a six
pence I have no idea what any of that is
okay so we we were metric out of the
gate
okay all right all right so let's just
put it putting it out there all right
all right let me give a shout out to
Jimmy Carter back when he was president
he tried to change all this right he
tried to put us on the metric system
with the rest of the world allocated
money out of Congress and it was
generally considered a failure
and you know
I hate to say it but so many things were
associated with him
[Music]
okay it didn't work out and he's a great
great president
a total heart in the right place guy yes
he was you know just just told America
the truth and that that you know I'm I'm
sorry but I just think the real problem
with America is that right now we have
lost confidence the threat
is nearly
invisible
in ordinary ways
it is a crisis
of confidence and people were just like
what
this is America
tell people you use confidence
you know and then all of a sudden you
know Reagan comes in like well there you
go again and all of a sudden people like
yeah that guy that's the guy we want
it's mourning in America
tear down that Mr gorbetov Mr Gorbachev
teared down this wall
[Applause]
they were like that's the guy
yeah yeah so anyway so
back to the metric systems do you know
the original definition of a meter where
it came from do you know no I tell you
okay okay by the way the French invented
the metric system okay
Wonder we hate it no no
and they foisted it upon the world after
the French Revolution that makes sense
you know what I mean but the guts the
way you measure is so wrong
why you're French why are they always
got to be smoking
but we do
we do we like to switch to smoke
cigarette
while we measure
this is in a new system we call the
metric system yeah so they pioneered it
so the definition the original
definition of meter
is
110 millionth
the distance
between the North Pole and the equator
along a line through the Paris
Observatory
oh wow
that is arrogant as hell
my God could you get any more arrogant
than that
because the line must run exactly
through the center of the Barry
Observatory where we will observe our
own Aragon look it was actually you know
what they also introduced which didn't
catch on decimal time
okay thank God for that because decimal
time sounds awful okay so there would be
the second is still a second okay but
there would be a hundred seconds in a
minute yeah see and then a hundred
minutes in an hour
and then 10 hours in a day there was
some way they did this it said so that
it worked out it all kind of worked out
right and there was some wrist watches
that had it and they're quite valuable
just as a Keepsake but nobody might have
one that'd be cool as hell to have them
I wouldn't know what you wouldn't be on
time for a damn thing
well nothing would change okay
all right let's keep going so we're
talking this is early 2020s okay
now what else used to not be metric and
is now metric I'll tell you uh
our nutrition labels nutrition labels
how so our nutrition labels are all
metric they're in grams as a person who
lives off of Funyuns and potato chips
okay
that uh
uh no this nutrition label you speak of
take a look it's how many grams of sugar
how many grams of fat that's true okay a
gram is metric that's okay all right so
that's right are you okay all right
nutrition labels all completely metric
okay true let's keep going photography
has basically always been metric now
this I know because I love taking
pictures and I own many cameras and all
lenses all lenses are you buy 35
millimeter film you shoot with a 50
millimeter lens 200 millimeter lens
that's right there was a two and a
quarter Square format
um which and an eight by ten you can buy
large negatives for large cameras but
buy it but basically all the photography
was metric as well as cinema 70
millimeters millimeters right okay okay
okay so that was that's always been
metric right all right let's keep shy
keep going yes okay let's go you have
never in your life purchased a a quart
of Pepsi
that's right okay I've only ordered
liters
if you or three liter three liter
bottles yeah well I don't know I'm not
sure how to get diabetes here three
liter bottle of Pepsi we are fluid you
go to I need two liters of Pepsi you
don't say oh I use liters I don't know
what a liter is okay okay let's keep
going okay wine is metric this is true
750 milliliter bottles yes they are that
I got about eight empty ones sitting
right right about eight feet from here
it happens to be like 26 and a half
ounces but that's not how you get the
bottle it's 750 milliliters we walk in
there buy it and no one is running for
the hills yeah well it's because it's
filled with delicious goodness okay
all right we'll keep going go ahead in
my day when I first learned how to drive
which was very late in my life okay I
learned when I was 25. wow my first car
you really are a New York kid yeah yeah
yeah yeah my first car was a Mercury
Montego oh okay eight cylinder all right
last of the land Yachts right yeah
you come up over a hill you know you
hope that nothing's walking in front of
the car because you can't see over the
front over the hood that's right where
something was crossing the street yeah
in front of the car comes over the hill
at four o'clock the back of the car
comes over the hill 4 15. 15 minutes
later
so so you do this
um so that car if you said how how big
is your engine 400 cubic inch that's
right
that's what it was
that was the that was the measure and
those you know what those cubic inches
we're measuring
no
okay it's not the size of the engine
block it's the volume
occupied in the boreholes for the
Pistons piston okay okay so that's some
measure of how much power the engine has
400 no it also Matters How heavy the car
is 400 cubic inch 350 cubic inch okay or
450 cubic inch these are how we measured
engines
through the 70s into the 80s and then
they slipped it in on you this is a
three liter engine yeah two and a half
liter engine
okay all right okay okay should I keep
going please okay
our entire electrical grid is metric
all right I'm I'm familiar now Watts oh
is metric that's right
okay okay if you don't want metric you
measure the lights in candle power
yeah there's a there's a candle is a
measure of Luminosity right right okay
right so so Watts amps
um ohms the resistance in a resistor all
of these units did not know those who
are all metric all metric okay all of it
okay
uh and now I think they're measuring the
power of air conditioners and Watts now
rather than what all I know the
difference would be calories
well calories are nutritional and those
are metric okay right that would be up
on your on your on your and calories is
energy not power so nowadays we talk
about kilowatt hours okay that's right
okay kilowatts kilowatt hours all of
this is metric so even lately I've been
seeing the power of air conditioners
measured in watts yes and
that's not how they always used to be
measured okay remember what the unit was
I do not
BTU BTUs yes British star
that's right okay
so I'm just saying we are inching
towards the metric system I see what you
did there
okay
we still have um I don't think we're
going to give up Fahrenheit
no I'll tell you why because the we like
our 10 degree increments in conversation
yes oh it's in the 30s outside which in
the 50s
it's in the 90s you know 90s right right
so that that has social value to retain
those increments because it's more
precise
than using Celsius so yes and by the way
Celsius sucks
like a true American yeah I mean come on
let's be free first ball you can't sing
a song you know uh uh 47 degrees in the
shade that doesn't work okay it's 96
degrees in the shade baby you know it
does it's yes no there's things we
wouldn't have to give up like it was a
milestone in your life No One's Gonna
say a kilometer Stone okay
and The Inchworm I think is still is
still
when you see it worm I mean what would
it be the millimeter worm no no no no
it's in fact it's called the worms the
measuring worm
stop it yes I think that's what they
call it in Europe the measuring worm
which is cool which is good they knew
not to call it a a centimeter worm that
you right okay okay they said okay they
should have gone with inchworm
so their things will retain I think but
I've given how much you have to adjust
when you're visiting another culture
anyway right you know miles and and
Fahrenheit is the least of your
adjustments you have to make if you're
visiting the United States that's true
that's kind of how I look at it my thing
is this we should be on the metric
system and because it really is just
reference anyway you don't the only
reason that we don't like the metric
system is because we have to convert
things to the metric system so if
everything were already metric it's
really just a uh a reference
philosophically deep yeah
the issue is converting and if
everything if you don't have to convert
anything
what difference does it make so the
laggards here is the dairy industry
all right they're not selling you liters
of milk no all right telling you quarts
of milk and they're not selling you 10
eggs and a gallon of milk and a dozen
eggs
they got a dozen they got pints quartz
quartz that's right cups
um and our cooking I don't see that
changing anytime soon right a cup a cup
of teaspoon tablespoon a tablespoon yeah
but all of that means nothing once it's
all
just references it doesn't make a
difference if you know right but so the
real issue is if you have to have a bake
off an international bake off and the
ingredients who they just give
measurements and you don't know what
units they're in if you just if you're
just Grandma cooking an old family
recipe at home yeah use a pinch of this
and a cup of that right and a Sprinkle
of this a dash of this so nobody's gonna
complain about that but there was a Mars
uh spacecraft launched by NASA
where the scientists established how
much fuel it should have for the final
burn to put it into orbit and the
engineers who were still using the
imperial system thought the amount of
fuel was in pounds instead of Newtons
Newtons is the metric measure of force
named after my boy Isaac and because
those are not the same quantities if you
think it's the same quantity and then
you build a spacecraft
then you will not have the amount of
fuel that you need and in fact the damn
spacecraft missed Mars oh my God yeah it
was a very it was egg on NASA's face
that is so much egg yeah that's a big
ass hey that's an omelette man that's a
omelette omelette crazy
that is that is straight up crazy so
that was embarrassing and so so
scientists have been metric you know for
most of the 20th century through today
of course and the engineers were a
little slow uh Architects might still be
a little time there I think uh but tools
kits you can buy metric toolkits running
on the same shelf oh and listen they now
when if you're trying to pick something
around the house the rulers they have on
one side you know the English units and
on the other side they got the metric
right and so that so that's why we're
not as bad as I think we think we are
for all the reasons I just stated yes
you know so what we should do is just go
ahead and make the switch
just go ahead and join the rest of the
world you know
um and uh just call it
mercymetric merch GPS and have your GPS
voice only tell you things in metric try
that
'd be kind of fun get you used to that
yeah we'll get yeah yeah in 300 meters
turn right and then I'd be like this not
going back to the uh regular units too
then they gotta have GPS with Attitude
no you're not
you missed your turn back the hell up
Chuck that's all I got for you
oh that was fun America inching towards
the metric system and I'm proud of us I
didn't think we'd get this far but we
man you you got a low bar
[Laughter]
this has been another star talk
explainer as always keep looking up
hot
[Music]